notre victoire rapporte 100 nicalis
président de l'observatoire national de
l'extrême droite merci d'être avec nous
monsieur porte en direct sur arte france
alors qu'avez vous pensé de la
mobilisation malgré une météo on peut le
dire un peu hostile
je crois que la mobilisation est réussie
parce que vous l'avez rappelé dans vos
titres et où 80 rassemblements dans
toute la france dans un contexte
sanitaire compliqué un couvre-feu à 18h
et une météo capricieuse en région
parisienne avec de la neige
on n'était pas descendue dans la rue
depuis le 5 décembre suite à une fin de
manifestations extrêmement tendu avec
les forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya des
centaines et des milliers de jeunes qui
sont redescendus pour exprimer leur
refus total de cette loi pas simplement
de l'article 24 mai d'une loi
liberticide et quelque part ils sont
venus exprimer le désir d'avoir une
société apaisée et non pas contrôlé par
un pouvoir gouvernemental de plus en
plus étendues alors un des syndicalistes
en tout cas qu'on a eue au micro de rtl
france un pendant cette manifestation
parisienne nous parlait justement de nos
deux nouveaux visages qui l'avait vu à
lors de ce rassemblement on parle
beaucoup de convergences des luttes
est-ce que c'est actuellement ce qui est
en train de se passer en france ça je me
garderai bien de le dire parce que vous
savez la convergence des luttes elle se
décrète pas elle se construit sur le
terrain mais il est vrai que dans les
mobilisations voit de plus en plus de
visage qu'on ne voyait pas dans les
manifestations traditionnelles et le
gouvernement il a tenté dès le départ
sur cette loi de faire ce qu'il fait
d'habitude c'est à dire de diviser et de
monter les gens les uns contre les
autres en disant que c'était simplement
les journalistes qui étaient mobilisés
pour défendre le droit de la presse et
l'arrêt de se battre contre le retrait
de l'article 24
en réalité les gens bien compris que
cette loi les ententes at war liberté
parce qu'à une privatisation de la
sécurité
il ya un usage massif des drones on
pourra même saisir les images de
vidéosurveillance dans les rôles
d'appartement donc c'est vraiment le
l'arrivée du bric brothers tel qu'on l'a
connu dans le livre de george orwell
donc c'est extrêmement dangereux les
gens comprennent mais c'est un
empilement de lois sécuritaires il faut
quand même se rappeler qu emmanuel
macron a commencé son mandat avec une
loi antiterroriste qui a inscrit dans le
droit ordinaire des dispositifs de la
juridiction d'exception
sur les cinq dernières années on a connu
trois des trois ans d'état d'urgence
qu'ils soient sanitaires ou sécuritaires
donc ça en dit long sur ce qui est en
train de se passer dans le pays
les gens ne veulent pas voir leurs
libertés individuelles et collectives
régressé et reculé aujourd'hui c'est lé
retrait total de cette loi que vous
espérez oui c'est le retrait total mais
je crois que le mot d'ordre depuis le
début de la mobilisation a été clair
l'article 24 à un peu braquer les
projecteurs sur lui parce qu'il est
absolument scandaleux surtout dans un
contexte où nous avons connu encore une
flambée des violences policières et je
pense évidemment à michel éclair ou
grâce aux images on a pu voir qu'ils
avaient été victimes de bavures mais
c'est tout le tout le corpus idéologique
de cette loi qui est passé sous état
d'urgence sanitaire alors qu'aujourd'hui
a aucune urgence à légiférer sur ces
questions là et on voit que le
gouvernement veut accélérer mais c'est
un peu ce que naomi klein appelle la
théorie du choc c'est à dire quand vous
avez un peuple est une situation qui est
difficile où il ya du repli sur soi
parce que la crise est compliqué on
essaye de passer des lois qui sont
impopulaires et cette loi les clarets
populaire donc il ya une nouvelle date
je crois de mobilisation la fin du mois
et le gouvernement il doit bien entendu
une chose c'est pas simplement l'article
24 c'est l'intégralité de ce projet de
loi qu'on souhaite voir retirer de
l'agenda politique
vous me disait entre manifestation la
fin du mois ce sera le 30 janvier cela
veut dire quoi que les manifestants
seront jusqu'au boutiste
ils seront pas jusqu'au-boutistes ils
sont revendicatif et ils exigent le
retrait de cette loi c'est pas être
jusqu'au boutiste de que de porter un
idéal de société mais d'ici la fin du
mois vous aurez d'autres data vous avez
les enseignants qui sont mobilisés vous
avez des professions de santé parce que
la colère sociale dans ce pays
elle est immense et quel que soit le
secteur concerné donc c'est pas du
jusqu'au boutisme je crois que le
jusqu'au boutisme il aujourd'hui du côté
du gouvernement qui s'enferre dans des
lois et d'intéressants mission
impopulaire et on peut parler ici de la
réforme des retraites où on a vu des
millions de gens dans la rue elle a été
retirée et voilà qu'elle va revenir dans
l'agenda politique
donc je crois que celles et ceux qui
refusent d'écouter ce qui se passe dans
le pays sont au gouvernement et ils
doivent entendre cette colère la est en
tout cas tant que ce projet de loi là ne
sera pas retirée il y aura des
mobilisations partout dans le territoire
je le dis encore une fois 80
rassemblements dans une période que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui c'est une véritable
réussite
thomas porte merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
syndicalistes et président de
l'observatoire national de
extrême droite merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct sur rtl france